grandio narcissism what you need to do
is you need to use the world to boost
your ego like if I think I'm a 10 but
I'm really a seven how do I go through
life feeling I'm a 10 well I can dress
up really well and then I can get a lot
of power and money and then I can
surround myself with people who tell me
I'm great the other thing is look at how
they treat people they're not interested
in that's interesting you're going to
see lost relationships broken business
deals I want multiple sexual partners
attractive sexual partners arm candy I
want to be a leader I want to be a
celebrity designer handbags designer
watches once they own those those kind
of become part of yourself we call it
the material self and What's creepy
about that because the goal is ego you
can swap those things out meaning I
could trade a new girlfriend for a new
Porsche and they do the same thing for
me they're substitutable like I have a
great girlfriend and somebody's like
dude I'll trade you her for a Porsche
what the hell I'm a product